gastronomie rockstar eine krawatte an
Hilfe von Francesco, unseren Marines und Ryan
Bourque-Kapital-Ideologie zu seinen Interessen
Ich muss am Pferdegrab arbeiten
alles durch eine drastische Landmesse und
Frau Asnar und Warda dieser Milliardär und
BNP Paribas
und ja, wie du danke und havas sagst
Es steigt dort an dem Holz anhaftend überhaupt nichts
Die Frage ist, ob Sie wollen
wie weit es gehen muss es war a
Milliardär heute Leute
reichsten der Welt, wo etwa 100
Milliarden Dollar pro Bill Gates
Jeff Bezos
bernard arnault, der mir gerade die bezahlt hat
frankreich die luxusindustrie
vor zehn Jahren der reichste
Milliardäre hatten etwa 30 Milliarden
alle zehn Jahre, bevor es 5 Milliarden waren
also die frage ist wie weit
Sie sehen, dass der Rhythmus zunimmt
Wachstum der Weltwirtschaft und
a fortiori der europäischen Wirtschaft bzw
Nordamerikaner aber auch der Wirtschaft
Welt als Ganzes ist viel
niedriger als dieser Satz
Erhöhung des Vermögensniveaus
also in einer in einer gesellschaft du
kann reich von arm haben
Mittelstand aber alles muss
die Welt wächst ein bisschen im gleichen Tempo
und so, wenn Sie das Niveau von haben
schlafende Vermögen, die wachsen
viel schneller als die Größe von
die Weltwirtschaft kann das nicht
weiter so auf unbestimmte Zeit also wir
ist verpflichtet, die Frage zu stellen
Was ist das richtige Maß an Ungleichheit und
alle menschlichen Gesellschaften und das war's
das Thema meines Bettes
Kapital und Ideologien diese beiden zu studieren
wie die verschiedenen Dinge das war
Der Mensch in der Geschichte versucht es
Endlich den richtigen Kompromiss finden
das richtige Maß an Gleichheit oder Ungleichheit
18% sowjetische Posen und eine Spur von
Mäuse haben sonst ein Interesse, wenn ich nehme
100 % der Betriebe und 10 % der Stimmen
20,6 mit schlanken Sprüngen g 10. Dank an
das sagt der app store in sin city folk
feldwebel christian weiss und viseu l'aja
weckt Befürchtungen, dann ist es
alles auf einmal, aber sicher ist
dass jede menschliche Gesellschaft und das ist es
das Thema meines Buches braucht
Begründungen dafür finden
Ebene der Gleichheit oder Ungleichheiten, die wir
Zirkus zu beobachten ist in allem nötig
menschliche Gesellschaften, um Sinn zu finden
Ungleichheiten, um uns selbst zu sagen, dass wir es nicht können
Sagen Sie einfach, es gibt keine menschliche Gesellschaft
wo die Eliten die dominierenden Gruppen sind
Ich freue mich, sagen zu können, dass wir hier sind
reich du bist arm und so ist es
es gibt immer mehr
der Raffinesse ca die Gruppen die
Reichere müssen sich zum Beispiel sagen
gut hier errichten wir Sie sind arm
aber es ist im interesse von
Innovation
die Stabilität der Gesellschaft ist notwendig
eine Begründung finden und wer muss
irgendeine Form von Plausibilität haben
und dem man auch Grenzen setzen muss
was ist eine akzeptable Ungleichheit, aber
zwischen diesem Leerzeichen und Zeichen in seinem
Kritik an dem Prinzen ist positiv zu bewerten
sagen, dass das natürlich ja Leute sind
anders, also völlige Gleichheit
würde also keinen sinn machen keine gesellschaft
strebt keine vollständige Gleichberechtigung an
Alle Unternehmen haben Sie eine gewisse
Ebene der sozialen Schichtung entweder
weil Menschen anders handeln
Berufliche Entscheidungen haben Geschmäcker
Unterschiedliche haben unterschiedliche Talente
verschiedene Berufungen entweder weil
dass wir der Meinung sind, dass es eine gewisse Zeit braucht
Ansporn zur Anstrengung und deshalb gibt es
immer ein gewisses Maß an Ungleichheit
See die Frage ist, was ist oder wo
wird aufhören, das ist die einzige Frage
das ist die einzig interessante frage
Ihre Stimme dort und dort versucht jede Gesellschaft
aus eigener Erfahrung lernen
mit erfahrungen versuchen wir es manchmal
Ungleichheiten manchmal verringern
wieder erhöhen
Nun, es gibt einen Prozess
Lernen in der Geschichte, aber ich
was ich habe, damit es drin ist
die langfristige
Ich habe eine Nachricht relativ
optimistisch, das heißt, ich denke, dass wir
so manchmal aus der Geschichte lernen
dieses Lernen ist nicht linear
mal gibt es Phasen der Regression
aber insgesamt sehen wir auf lange Sicht
Begriff
eine Bewegung hin zu mehr Gleichberechtigung und
diese Verringerung der Ungleichheiten in der
langfristig
sie war außerordentlich positiv
das erlaubte nicht nur mehr
soziale Mobilität mehr Emanzipation
Individuum durch Zugang zu Bildung
Gesundheit, sondern auch mehr Wohlstand
Wirtschaft und diese langfristige Bewegung
Gerechtigkeit lernen u
Abbau von Ungleichheiten
Ich denke, kann und sollte fortgesetzt werden, wenn es so ist
war einmal Lehrer an der Pariser Schule
der Wirtschaftswissenschaften
Wir sagen, es wird gut, Dr. Avatar
zu der zeit als ich an den start kam
begann seine historische Forschung
erstens, weil diese Quellen
Die Geschichte wurde nie verwendet
das heißt, es ging um
Archiv Der Erfolg wird das Archiv sein
Steuer war eine Sache, die war
vielleicht zu historisch für
Ökonomen und zu sparsam für die
Historiker und damit niemand
benutzt, also fing ich an
darin das Studium dieser Materialien
historische erste für frankreich seitdem
das 19. Jahrhundert
dann für die Vereinigten Staaten mit
emmanuel saez dann mit tony atkinson an
erweiterte es auf das Vereinigte Königreich und schließlich
Wir haben Dutzende von Ländern studiert
in der Welt und ist jetzt haben wir
mit der Welt eine Gleichstellungsdatenbank
Wir haben jetzt mehr als 70 Länder in der
Welt, für die wir die Größten haben
historische Datenbank auf
die Entwicklung der Ungleichheiten am Anfang mich
als ich hinein kam ich
wusste nicht wirklich, was ich vorhatte
finden und dann habe ich Dinge gefunden
die sich von Land zu Land unterscheiden
am auffälligsten von zwei vor
Entdeckungen, die mich zuerst beeindruckten
sehen, wie in Ländern wie
Frankreich und allgemein in der
europäische Unternehmen
Sie müssen wirklich auf die Premiere warten
Weltkrieg, um eine Bewegung zu sehen
Abbau von Ungleichheiten Zirkus vor
es war dort das allgemeine Wahlrecht
da war die entwicklung zuerst
Sozialpolitik, sondern Ungleichheiten
weiterhin auf Niveau
extrem hoch und es stimmt, dass dort
hatte große Heuchelei in der
Europäische Gesellschaften vor 1914
Sprechen in meinem Land in Frankreich
Eliten der Dritten Republik
weigerte sich, eine progressive Steuer zu schaffen
auf das Einkommen, das letztendlich sein wird
angenommen in Frankreich durch das Gesetz vom 15
Juli 1914
nicht um Schulen zu finanzieren, sondern
um den Krieg zu finanzieren
Deutschland
es ist der einzige Faktor, dass
Endlich entsperrt sich die Situation a
Ausreden
eines der Argumente der Eliten
Französisch zu der Zeit war es 2
lacht, aber wir in Frankreich haben wir das gemacht
Französische Revolution
Wir sind also bereits ein egalitäres Land
braucht keine Einkommenssteuer
im Gegensatz zu unseren englischen Nachbarn
aristokratisch bis preußisch autoritär
wer braucht sie außer uns als wir
ist bereits ein Land der Gleichberechtigung
es lohnt sich nicht außer mir was
Ich finde in meinen historischen Daten
ist das in der Tat die Konzentration der
Reichtum in Frankreich vor 1914 ist
genauso extrem wie in den anderen
europäische Unternehmen
Das ist also die erste Lektion
das traf mich, weil sagen wir zu einem
Jahrhundert entfernt
wir sehen manchmal die Heuchelei der Gruppen
dominant, um ein bestimmtes zu rechtfertigen
Ebene der Ungleichheit die zweite
Entdeckung, die uns sehr beeindruckt hat
mit Emmanuel Saez
es ist der sehr starke Anstieg in
Ungleichheiten in den Vereinigten Staaten seit dem
80er und das haben wir nicht mitbekommen
zählen Sie sofort, weil es ist
stimmt, dass wir in unserer ersten Studie
veröffentlichte im Jahr 2003 die Daten, deren
Wir haben, glaube ich, 1998 aufgehört
und damals hatten wir ein Comeback
seit 1981, aber es blieb
begrenzt und dann auf die Straße und wir
menditte terror kostenloser mittagessen vorverkauf
Beispiel oder Privatfrau ein Veilchen
schätzen sie usa andrew auf flughafenanfrage
tanzen heute abend marina vor ort zwischen 102 und
schätzt, dass es diese aufgefüllt wurde
Großhändler werden darunter leiden dann Sie
hast du recht da ist einer
langfristige Reduzierung der
Ungleichheiten und das ist die Dimension
Optimist meines Buches, dh ich
Ich denke, es gibt eine Bewegung von
Abbau langfristiger Ungleichheiten
Begriff, den wir sehr gut sehen
zumindest auf europa dann auf der
USA haben wir einen Aufschwung aber sogar
in den Vereinigten Staaten bleibt es etwas niedriger
als
Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts so diese Bewegung
Langfristig ist es eine Realität
zugleich der zweite Punkt, den ich
hinzufügen möchten, ist, dass, wenn wir zeigten
in dieser grafik der anteil der 50%
insgesamt am ärmsten
Eigentum würden wir das in Europa als sehen
in den USA
es sind ungefähr 5% der Gesamtmenge, so dass
bedeutet das auch heute noch
siehe die reichsten 10% haben dazwischen
55 und 75 % der Gesamtsumme
die unteren 50%, die sind
doch fünfmal zahlreicher als
Die reichsten 10 % haben nur 5 % der
insgesamt also fünfzehnmal weniger als die
die 10 % reichsten früh, dass Sie
lässt erahnen, dass es zwei gedauert hat
Dinge sind sowohl im Gewächshaus als auch bei wahr
die Zeit, in der es eine Reduzierung gab
langfristigen Ungleichheiten und gleichzeitig
Ungleichheiten bleiben sehr stark
das heißt, dass in Bezug auf das Gesicht zu sagen
Eigentum der Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung die ärmsten 50% in
schweiz heute
oder sogar zwei Drittel der Schweizer
die Ärmsten haben fast nichts und
vor allem Kinder aus
beliebte Klassen und Klassen
Durchschnitte werden nichts erben und werden es nicht
Besitzt fast hohes Riad ist es nicht notwendig
Ungleichheiten werden abgebaut
langfristig und das dürfen wir nicht
Übertreiben Sie seine Größe mehr als nötig
Erfolg der Realität ist es komplex
es gibt sowohl eine Reduzierung in
Ungleichheit
aber innerhalb einer Welt, die sehr bleibt
ungleich
Odinga hatte Kapital renton raw getestet
handtuch bei af mark stone und smic
also helfe ich besonders dabei, dass
ist die Kapitalrendite für
die wichtigsten Vermögenswerte und für
die beliebtesten Finanzportfolios
wichtig
was sehr hoch ist und was höher ist
dass die Wachstumsrate der Wirtschaft
Kapitalrendite im Durchschnitt
ist nicht unbedingt sehr wichtig und das
Kapitalrendite, die durch erzielt wurde
kleine Sparer
also wenn du auch 5000 franken hast
Schweizer auf Ihrem Bankkonto
du wirst kein sehr gutes haben
Rendite derzeit aber auf der anderen Seite
Leute, die 5 Milliarden haben
Geldbeutel Schweizer Franken
was wir in den Daten beobachten
verfügbar auf den Ranglisten von
wohlhabende Milliardäre oder auf
bessere Datenqualität, das ist
zum Beispiel die Renditen auf
universitäre Kapitalausstattung
Amerikaner oder Universitäten
internationale, die ich hier studiere
buchen, weil wir sehr gute haben
Daten über getätigte Investitionen und
was wir beobachten, ist das für für
die wichtigsten Stiftungen von
mehrere Milliarden oder mehrere
mehrere zehn Milliarden Dollar
Wir haben tatsächlich Renditen
von 7 8 9 % pro Jahr zusätzlich zu
Inflation
so nach dem Entfernen der Inflation alle
Verwaltungsgebühren und diese sind
Erträge, die Wachstum ermöglichen
von diesen seiner Kapitalausstattung ist
auch von den höchsten Vermögen der Welt
die natürlich viel höher sind
als die Wachstumsrate, aber ich
möchte darauf bestehen, dass es das gibt
nichts davon ist kein Naturgesetz
Sire, dass es auf ein bestimmtes ankommt
Organisation des Finanzsystems
Rechtssystem international
international, was zu haben erlaubt
Zugang zu bestimmten Investitionen zu haben
bestimmte derivative Produkte extrem
anspruchsvoll, die sehr schwierig sind
betreten
wenn du 5000 Franken hast
Kaufen Sie keine Derivate
aus rohen Materialien
an der Börse von Hongkong ist dies
nur wenn du Geld hast
viel wichtiger zu platzieren als
Sie können auf diese Produkte zugreifen
sehr raffinierte Derivate
es hängt auch von einem Rechtssystem ab
freier Kapitalverkehr ohne
gemeinsame Besteuerung ohne Tausch
Informationen darüber, wem was gehört bzw
was oft erlaubt
zu den größten Unternehmen, sondern auch
am meisten an die Inhaber des Erbes
um der Steuer zu entgehen, die von der bezahlt wird
Mittelschichten und Klassen
Beliebt
Es ist also ein ganzes Rechtssystem
eine Organisation der Wirtschaft, die
führt dazu, dass es kein Naturgesetz ist
vom Himmel fallen
Heute denke ich, dass wir eins sind
ein bisschen wie ein Zirkuskreuz, wir zögern dazwischen
Einige Visionen, die wir vergessen haben, denke ich
Die Lehren der ersten Hälfte des 20
Jahrhundert, das ist auch eine Welt
ungleich wie die des neunzehnten
Jahrhunderts und Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts
Es ist eine sehr instabile Welt
politisch sozial ökonomisch
mit Finanzkrisen des des
soziale Konflikte, die ich denke haben
beigetragen zu anderen ist eine heftige Krise
vom Beginn des 20. Jahrhunderts bis zur Entstehung
des ersten weltkriegs zweiten
Weltkrieg der Revolution
Bolschewistische Krise der 1930er und
diese ganze Abfolge von Ereignissen
extrem gewalttätig zwischen 1914 und 1945
sind zu einem großen Teil die
Folge der Hyper-Ungleichungen von
Gesellschaften vor 1914
heute haben wir wir ein wenig vergessen sein
Unterricht dann gab es eine Phase dazwischen
1950 1980, als wir offensichtlich sehr waren
traumatisiert von diesen Schocks und wir
versuchte, die zurückgegangene Wirtschaft zu vertiefen
das kapitalistische System als Ganzes
von Regeln, die wir so nennen können
sozialdemokratischer Kompromiss mit a
Sozialversicherungssystem der
Regulierung der Finanzmärkte von
Progressives Steuerarbeitsrecht
ermöglicht in diesem System die kastriert
Problem ist das seit Jahren
1980 1990 haben wir unseren Unterricht irgendwie vergessen
pro Jahr
Erstens, weil Unternehmen oft
Menschen haben ein kurzes Gedächtnis
Sag ja, es ist wahr, deshalb
dass Geschichte wichtig ist
sagen, dass die Geschichte dieser re wiederholen
Fragen zum Beispiel nehme ich a
Beispiel, viele Leute vergessen es
als das, was im 20. funktionierte
Jahrhundert ist es ein sehr
entschlossen, Ungleichheiten abzubauen
des kapitalistischen Systems in den Vereinigten Staaten
der Weltwirtschaftsführer war
des kapitalistischen Systems im 20. Jahrhundert
zwischen 1930 und 1980 der Steuersatz
auf das höchste angewandte Einkommen
durchschnittlicher Umsatz 81%
und offensichtlich tat es das nicht
verschwinden das kapitalistische System und
Vereinigten Staaten, weil es dauerte
ein halbes Jahrhundert von 1930 bis 1980 und so weiter
Viele Menschen haben es heute vergessen
was soll ich sagen, wenn du das sagst
heute sagen die Leute dir ah aber
bolschewistische ccc ist die sowjetunion
und war der höchste
das heißt, dass tatsächlich das Wachstum
System mich versuche ich zu bringen
diese Frage der historischen Elemente
um zu zeigen, dass diese Raten von 80% auf
sehr sehr hohes Einkommen
nein absolut nicht das Wachstum gehemmt
wirtschaftlich warum weil das
angewendet auf Einkommensniveaus bzw
Glück wirklich sehr sehr hoch so
Salz ist eine vernünftige Ungleichung
zwischen den Arbeitern die Manager die
Manager, aber das schloss Ungleichheiten aus
exzessiv, es ermöglichte auch die Finanzierung
eine Anlagepolitik in
Infrastruktur in der Bildung, die hat
erlaubt, einen Konsens herzustellen
sozial auf der Tatsache, dass die Klassen
Mittelschichten mussten die Arbeiterklassen
auch durch ihre Steuern zum beitragen
Finanzierung eines neuen Sozialsystems
aber als die reichsten beitragen
sogar mehr
es war etwas, das war
dann gesellschaftsfähig
das ist heute eines der Probleme, die wir haben
ist das angesichts der fiskalischen Sezession
der Reichsten
die Tatsache, dass die Reichen können
Klassen können der Steuer entgehen
bedeutet, dass die Arbeiterklassen haben
den Eindruck gehabt zu haben und so
Fragen Zustimmung
MwSt
den ganzen Gesellschaftsvertrag
Ich schlage vor, diese Perioden noch einmal zu besuchen
Ich bringe viele Elemente mit
Geschichte, um das endlich zu beschließen
Diese Experimente verliefen recht gut
dann funktionierte diese Überlegung
historisch
es ist wahr, dass er immer noch anspruchsvoll ist
intellektuell, d.h. du ich
Fragen Sie nach Aktion, warum wir es vergessen haben
Es gibt viele Leute, wenn Sie
Lassen Sie mich Donald Trump erklären
dass diese Vergleiche gemacht werden sollten
Geschichte, dass Sie sich die Rate ansehen müssen
Wachstum in den 1950er 1960er Jahren
Donald Trump, er hat schon aufgehört zuzuhören
und er wird es mir erzählen, aber das ist die Geschichte
Fick hier, ich weiß, ich habe meine
Kaufmanns Intuition über das, was er
Heute im Jahr 2001 muss ich aber denke ich
auf die wir nicht fallen dürfen
Donald Trump
du musst du musst mich akzeptieren, frage ich
einschließlich Menschen a priori
skeptischer gegenüber seiner Steuer
sehr progressiv auf sehr hoch
Einkommen aus der Zustimmung zum Ansehen der
historische Erfahrungsdaten
Geschichten, die ich präsentiere und dann
sich eine eigene Meinung zu bilden
Abbas bestand darauf, dass Henri Mash Life dies regelte
Fluss eines Gesundheitssystems ist schwierig
aber es ist nicht unmöglich
und vor allem ist es das Einzige, was wir haben
das heißt, wenn wir uns weigern zu schießen
Lehren aus der Geschichte, das ist
Was wir übrig haben, haben wir so hinterlassen
jeder sagt, was ihm durch den kopf geht
und jeder von euch kennt diese Zeit
Zuerst sagst du, es gab
Steuerhinterziehung, ist es aber nicht
stimmt, dass es die gleichen Ungleichheiten gab
das, was es heute gibt, gab es
es hat einen echten Rückgang gegeben
Ungleichheiten ist es nicht, dass die
Menschen waren war genauso reich
schaffte es aber, der Steuer-Nr. zu entkommen
es hat wirklich einen Rückgang gegeben
Ungleichheit
Ich bestehe auch darauf, wenn wir aus Erfahrung sprechen
der Vereinigten Staaten ist besonders
interessant, weil manchmal, wenn wir
schau nach europa sagte ja aber
die nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ist
eine Phase der wirtschaftlichen Aufholjagd
also schwer zu vergleichen
im Vergleich zur letzten Zeit und es ist
stimmt das für
Hop, es ist schwierig, diese Art von zu tun
Vergleich für die Vereinigten Staaten
in der Tat, wenn wir uns die Zeit um 1950 ansehen
1990, wenn die Einkommenswachstumsrate
National pro Kopf beträgt 2 2 % pro Jahr
im Durchschnitt
in der Tat ist es keine Periode
besonders außergewöhnlich ist
ähnlich wie zwischen 1910 und
1950 mit 2% pro Jahr und 1870 5910
waren 1,9 % pro Jahr, also eher a
etwas besser 1950 1990, aber es ist nicht sehr
anders aber seit dem Jahrzehnt
Reggan zwischen 1990 und 2020
dort fielen wir auf 1,1 Prozent pro Jahr
so in Bezug auf das Versprechen von
Wachstum durch ankurbeln
niedrigere Steuern für Unternehmer
und die Milliardäre
Es gibt immer noch ein Problem, weil
Nun, wenn wir daran glauben wollen
Trickle-Down-Theorie-Diskurs
das stricken gibt von ronald reagan
sollte erklären, warum die
Wachstum war im Begriff, durch geteilt zu werden
vier und dank Reggane
es wurde nur halbiert
aber es ist immer noch nicht einfach zu sehen
als historische Argumentation I halten
Denken Sie an eine Verringerung des Wachstums
seit dem reagan-jahrzehnt ist es das erste
aufgrund der Stagnation von
die Bildungsinvestition, die es zum macht
Wohlstand der Vereinigten Staaten historisch
es basierte zunächst auf ihrer Führung
Bildungsbegriffe über Europa
es war ein Land, das im 19. Jahrhundert und
bis Mitte des 20. Jahrhunderts hatte
ein großer Fortschritt in Sachen Bildung
und dieser Vorsprung ist seitdem verloren gegangen
80er 90er und es ist die Erzählung, die hat
wurde in den 80er Jahren erfunden
Wachstum hängt davon ab
Ungleichheit und Haben
Milliardäre Unternehmer sehr
sehr reich, wer diese Rede hält, er
hätte wahr sein können, aber angesichts dessen
die Geschichte
Ich denke, wir können daraus schließen, dass es so ist
eher Gleichstellung in der Bildung bei a
gewisse Gleichheit durch vollkommene Gleichheit
sondern ein Bildungssystem, das investiert
in sehr großen Segmenten der
Bevölkerung, die Wohlstand ermöglicht
wirtschaftlich
Ich finde mich selbst der Schlüssel ja ja das denke ich
der Aufstieg des Populismus und insbesondere
der Aufstieg des Nationalismus auf der rechten Seite
Das politische Spektrum ist groß
Teil die Folge eines Gefühls
Aufgabe der beliebten Klassen und
Mittelschicht und ich denke das
ist kein Zufall, dass die Staaten
Vereinigte und das Vereinigte Königreich, die die beiden sind
Länder, in denen wir am stärksten waren
Zunahme der Ungleichheit seitdem
80er Jahre sind auch die beiden Länder, in denen wir
hatte die Wahl von Trump und dem Kombi
Website, das heißt, es gab eine
Versprechen von Reagan und Thatcher, dass die
Globalisierungswettbewerb
weit verbreitet auf dem Markt war
Wohlstand für alle schaffen
Welt und dann die Mittelschicht und
die beliebten Klassen in den Vereinigten Staaten und
In Großbritannien habe ich das noch nicht gesehen
Wohlstand und es ist weitgehend
warum trumpf
dreißig Jahre später versuchen, zu finden
Erklärungen, indem man sagt, es ist
Schuld sind die Mexikaner
der Chinesen ist es die Schuld der
Europäer, für die sie nicht genug bezahlen
Die NATO ist die Schuld des Rests
Welt und die Pausensitter bei
uk es war ein bisschen das gleiche es ist
Schuld sind die polnischen Arbeiter
Also dieser nationalistische Diskurs ja ich
denke, es ist weitgehend die
Folge der Tatsache, dass es eine gab
Anstieg der Ungleichheit gab es keine
alternativer Diskurs zu versuchen
Reorganisation der Globalisierung von a
Weg, der mehr nützt
Mittelschichten und Klassen
beliebt und Sie kennen diesen Aufstieg der
Nationalismus jetzt und Bedenken
ganz Europa und auch Konzerne
Deutschland, wo die Mitte-Rechts
sogenannten Mitte-Rechts vor ein paar Jahren
Wochen mit der extremen Rechten abgestimmt
für eine Regionalregierung
es betrifft mein land frankreich
offensichtlich wo die extreme Rechte mit dem
Stift war sehr mächtig für
Jahrzehnte so, wenn wir nicht nehmen
nicht ernsthaft das
nas, die zusammenzubrechen drohen
unser demokratisches Modell unser Modell
der Globalisierung
Ich denke, es wäre wirklich ein
großer Fehler und ein sehr hohes Risiko
wichtig, dass wir unsere laufen würden
Quellen, die der Partitur zugeordnet wurden
die Bullen in der Francis-Fukuyama-Straße
jahre andré valentin veronique in hocke
in die stadt der kater 2 einwanderung
Sagen Sie Traum handeln Ort mit Nintendo Krise
haben 10 m vor einem großen sind nicht
montiert wählt samstag zu einer normalen familie
hatte ein gutes gefühl dabei
gehört, dass wie gesagt fukuyama die
Als wirtschaftlicher Schaden wird interpretiert
kulturellen Begriffen und es ist gegeben
Lösungen kulturelle Lösungen
identitätsbasiert
aber die Frage ist, tun Sie diese
kulturelle Interpretationen zu
identitätsbasierte Interpretationen
Was für ein Dampfer
Wagen Sie Trump oder was wird der Kombi vorschlagen
Website wird es lösen
Probleme
Nun, ich denke nicht, das heißt ich
denke, dass in der Tat der Aufstieg von
Ungleichheit
es wird mit diesem Rückgang fortfahren
nationalistisch und dieser Wettbewerb
verstärkt zwischen den Ländern Blick auf die
Trump-Politik Steuerpolitik
von Trumpf, der darin besteht, immer zu senken
zuzüglich Unternehmenssteuern
multinationale Konzerne oder Milliardäre
wie er selbst wollte er sogar löschen
volle erbschaftsteuer
auf Milliardäre ist es okay
Helfen Sie dem Mittelstand, wo die Klasse
beliebte Amerikanerin, die Schulden hat
Ursache der sehr teuren Universität, die hat
Schulden wegen eines Gesundheitssystems
sehr teuer, aber um seine Probleme zu lösen
von Schulden
das sind Probleme, die müssen
begleichen durch Umverteilung durch
wirtschaftliche Lösungen, wenn es
Identitätsdiskurse Diskurse
Nationalisten
offensichtlich sind sie einfacher als
Lösungen, dass ich sein Land verteidige
Ich spreche in diesem Buch über Soziales
Partizipativer Sozialismus Föderalismus
das sind Reden, die sind
kompliziert es ist wahr, dass die Rede
zurück an den östlichen Grenzen von
zurück zu der Identität, die diese sind
extrem einfache Rede, die
haben heute den Wind in den Segeln
mangels Alternative aber gleichzeitig
Zeit, wenn Sie seine Reden wollen, tun sie es nicht
wird die Probleme nicht lösen
Ungleichheit noch die Probleme
umwelt sirte wo groß
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit, sei es die
steigende Ungleichheit globale Erwärmung
Klima Nachfrage
Internationalismus erfordert
internationale Kooperation
so hat dieser nationalistische Rückzug
heute der wind in den segeln
aber am ende der enden geht es nicht
löse die Probleme und los geht's
auf Lösungen zurückkommen müssen
viel internationaler viel
egalitärer und ich denke, das müssen wir
auch heute vorbereiten
und darüber hinaus diese Entwicklung und wir
bereits begonnen, wenn Sie sich ansehen
innerhalb der demokratischen Partei in den Vereinigten Staaten
Sie haben Reden über die
Umverteilung, die nicht gehen kann
triumphierte sofort, aber wer denke ich
letztendlich zur Transformation beitragen wird
Reden und Vorschläge, die sind
geschaffen, um Ungleichheiten abzubauen
weil wir es wissen
Ich denke, dass ein Kandidat wie
Bernie Sanders oder als Elizabeth Warren
Nun, es wäre schön gewesen, wenn er ein wenig gewesen wäre
jünger, aber auf jeden Fall ich
denke, sie wären besser gewesen als Joe
biden zur Wahl zu bringen
die junge Wählerschaft die populäre Wählerschaft
die sehr oft aufhören zu wählen
die demokratische Partei und du weißt, ob Joe
biden bemüht sich nicht, es zu versuchen
zu sammeln und zu versuchen
greifen einige der Vorschläge von auf
Bernie Sanders und Den Elizabeth Warren
Jugendliche zum Unterricht zu bringen
beliebt bei den Wahlen im Herbst
dann besteht wirklich die Gefahr, dass Trump
wiedergewählt werden, weil im Jahr 2016, was wir haben
nur zum ersten Mal beobachtet
Hillary Clinton Parteikandidat
Der Demokrat tat tatsächlich sein Bestes
zählen zu den Bestverdienern
stehen zum ersten mal da
Die Wahlgeschichte der Vereinigten Staaten
es waren die Demokraten, die es taten
ihr bestes Ergebnis gegen
Republikaner im Einkommensniveau
die höchste und nicht nur in
die höchsten Abschlussstufen
was bei einigen schon der Fall war
Jahrzehnte
es gibt also einen allmählichen Schlupf a
vollständige Umkehrung, was in der Tat bedeutet
die Demokratische Partei, die einst anzog
die beliebtesten Stimmen
bescheidene Kategorien beginnt zu sein
hauptsächlich die Partei der Kategorien
die beliebtesten, also die Frage
Daran wollen wir anknüpfen
auf diese Weise, was bis zur Achselhöhle kommt
der Boden für Trump und für die Parteien
Nationalisten gegenüber
beliebt und wir haben die gleiche Herausforderung
heute in europa
der Appetit auf Politik reimt sich zu sehr
Philosophie wiederholt er Ich habe Lampenfieber und
nebliges finale karl marx david für zwecke
of match ist ein Philosoph, den wir dann kennen
es gibt wirklich viele
Unterschiede zwischen zwischen zwischen meinen Büchern
und die von karl marx
der erste unterschied bin erstmal ich
Ich betreibe empirische Forschung
historisch
es ist eine Sozialwissenschaft, die sich darauf stützt
zunächst zur Datenerhebung
beträchtliche Geschichte in diesem Buch
Es gibt 169 Diagramme und Tabellen
gut, wenn du karl marx liest
kann keine Diagramme finden
es ist also immer noch groß
Unterschied, denn dann ist es nicht
das heißt, es war viel schwieriger
im 19. Jahrhundert zu sammeln
historische Daten als es ist
heute also will ich nicht ich will
auch wenn sie nicht karl marx die schuld geben
er hätte mehr tun können
Versuch, weniger abstrakt zu sein
theoretisch und ein wenig mehr empirisch und
Geschichte Ich nehme an, es ist ein Teil
aber es war auch wahr
viel schwieriger also für für
Heute können wir abholen
Daten sammeln
und vor allem haben wir all die Erfahrung
20. Jahrhundert, also mir die g 150 Jahre
historische erfahrung seit karl marx
und das ändert alles, denn im zwanzigsten
Jahrhunderts hat sich viel getan
Dinge
es gab die Katastrophe des Kommunismus
Sowjetischen gab es die Erfolge der
Sozialdemokratie und mit der Zeit die
Grenzen auch des Sozialen
Demokratie am Ende der Periode
und ich versuche, eine zu bauen
Wirtschaftsgeschichtliche Reflexion
Philosophische Politik auf der Grundlage von
diese erfahrungen und karl marx wenn er wäre
heute noch am Leben, ich weiß nicht, was
was sie von zwei der Partei halten würden
chinesischer kommunist heute
Sowjetischer Kommunismus
Sozialdemokratie also hier habe ich die
glücklich, dort zu sein, um in der Lage zu sein, diese zu verwenden
Experimente zur allgemeinen Vision von
die Geschichte
vielleicht ist der Hauptunterschied
dass ich denke, dass der Kampf von
Klassen ist wichtig, aber es ist
vielleicht weniger wichtig als der Kampf
Ideen Ideologien, das heißt
dass die Klasse den Konflikt widerspricht
sozial offensichtlich ist es sehr wichtig
und wir haben es vor kurzem wieder gesehen
Soziale Bewegungen in Chile im Libanon
oder bei den Gelbwesten in Frankreich mit
diese Forderung nach sozialer Gerechtigkeit in der
Straße mit Demonstrationen und so
weiter
und es wird weiterhin eine Rolle spielen
wichtig in der Geschichte, aber das tut es nicht
nicht genug, weil die Position von
Klasse als solche reicht nicht aus
bestimmen
ein politisches Ventil reicht nicht aus
eine Eigentumstheorie aufstellen
ein ideales Steuerregime ein Regime
Bildungsideal und daher Bedarf besteht
von Ideen der Ideologie und ich denke, dass a
Fehler von Marx oder irgendeiner Art
der marxistischen Reflexion ist das Denken
das ist die Klassenlage als
dass dies eine Theorie des Handelns gibt
und es ist genug zu tun
das System des Privateigentums aufbrechen
Kapitalist und dann am nächsten Tag
Morgen nach der großen Nacht legen wir ein
Eigentumsemanzipatorisches Modell
Kollektiv
wir sahen wir sahen was es so gab
Angesichts dieser Erfahrung halte ich es für notwendig
das Thema ernst nehmen
Reflexion darüber, wie wir organisieren a
jedes andere Eigenschaftssystem
anders als das Eigentumssystem
rein kapitalistisch, aber was zugleich
Zeit ist sehr dezentralisiert und das ist
warum mir was ich dem vorschlage
Ende des Buches mit dieser Idee von
Der partizipative Sozialismus ist ein System
stark dezentralisiert mit über
Rechte für Arbeitnehmer
Arbeitnehmervertreter
weit verbreiteter Zugang zu Eigentum für
alle Gruppen in der Gesellschaft wie wir
sah früher die oberen 50%
arm heute haben nichts und
Ich denke, es muss Zugang geben
viel breiter an der kleinen
Privateigentum also alles, was macht
viel viel Unterschied mit
mit karl marx eben eben
progressiv und offshore
[Musik]
so schlage ich vor, die zu ersetzen
rein kapitalistisches System durch a
System des partizipativen Sozialismus, das
basiert auf zwei Hauptsäulen
zunächst einmal das Co-Management, also die
Tatsache, dass Arbeitnehmervertreter
kann einen erheblichen Teil davon haben
Stimmrechte in Unternehmen
so aktuell wie ihr wisst in
Deutschland hält 50 % der Stimmrechte
für Arbeitnehmervertreter in
die Vorstände
große Aufsichtsräte
unternehmen in schweden sind es 35%
aber es gilt für kleinere
Firmen
Ich denke, wir können 50 % auf haben
alle kleinen Unternehmen u
groß
und ich denke, dass dieses System es möglich gemacht hat
Mitarbeiter besser einbeziehen
Anlagestrategien
langfristige Geschäfte, denke ich, wir
kann weiter gehen Ich denke, es ist notwendig
man kann auch daran denken, die zu begrenzen
Stimmrechte der Aktionäre
einzelnen Gewächshaus als in einem großen
Unternehmen
kein einzelner Aktionär könnte dies tun
über mehr als 10 % der Stimmrechte verfügen
Möglichkeit, die Beratung Dritter zu erzwingen
Die allgemeine Philosophie ist, dass wir leben
in hoch gebildeten Gesellschaften, wo
alle sollen mitmachen können
der wirtschaftliche Entscheidungszirkus, den Sie haben
viele Ingenieurmitarbeiter aus
Führungskräfte von Mitarbeitern, die etwas haben
um die Idee hervorzubringen, dass es nur gibt
Mitglieder der Gründerfamilie
des Unternehmens oder diejenigen, die
verheiratet mit der Familie des Gründers von
das Unternehmen, das dazu berechtigt ist
an der Entscheidungsfindung teilnehmen
Das Unternehmen, das ich dachte, ist eine Vision
was nicht der realität entspricht
unsere Gesellschaften extrem gebildet in
die wir brauchen eine Zirkulation der
Macht des Eigentums, das ist also die
Teil eins, das nenne ich
soziales Eigentum mit einem Segel zu
sehr starke Beteiligung von
Arbeitnehmervertreter
der zweite Teil, von dem ich spreche
temporäres Eigentum ist die Idee, dass
die sehr hohe Eigentumsquote von
Erbe muss der Gesellschaft zurückgegeben werden
Teil davon dieser Eigenschaft
regelmäßig bei mir will ich einen
Gesellschaft, in der jeder sein kann
Besitzer in Proportionen
vernünftig auf jeder muss
Zugang zu einer Immobilie haben
ein paar hunderttausend
Euro teilweise von wenigen
Millionen, die ein Unternehmer gehabt hätte
Viel Erfolg konnte zugreifen 10
Millionen oder 20 Millionen auf der anderen Seite sobald
Milliardär Sir People Who
besitzen 10 Milliarden 50 Milliarden 100
Milliarden Euro auf Basis von
historische Erfahrungen, die ich habe
Ich denke, es ist nicht nützlich
das heißt, es liegt nicht daran
es ist nicht, weil jemand es getan hat
Vermögen im Alter von 30 Jahren, das er hatte
manchmal hatte er gute Ideen
Chance oder beides gleichzeitig, dass dies
niemand sollte dann weitermachen können
um die ganze Macht zu konzentrieren, um zu nehmen
Entscheidungen im Alter von 50 im Alter
von 70 bis 90 Jahren in
Unternehmen, die manchmal enthalten
Tausende Zehntausende von
Hunderttausende von Mitarbeitern und die
Entscheidungen, die zu treffen sind, sind es auch
kompliziert, damit wir das mögen können
wollte mich auf eine Person konzentrieren
also diese Art der Sakralisierung von
ddd Milliardär, wo ein paar Leute
wie Sade weitermachen kann
Entscheidungen über Standards treffen
Technologieunternehmen auf der Ebene
weltweit oder in anderen Branchen
Aktivität, die meiner Meinung nach entspricht
eine etwas monarchische Vorstellung von
die Physioökonomie, die nicht alles ist
einfach nicht an die Realität angepasst ist
dass die Haie 46 viele erregten
interne ereignisse gegen paris bercy
und da fielst du einem zum Opfer
Illusionsideologie, du weißt nicht was
was die meisten Unternehmer tun
schweiz oder in deutschland oder in frankreich
sind keine Milliardäre
die meisten Unternehmer, wenn sie es schon sind
schaffe es, ein paar Millionen anzusammeln
Schweizer Franken oder ein paar Zehner
Millionen Schweizer Franken
es ist bereits ein großer Erfolg und diese sind
die Leute, die es zum Laufen bringen
die Wirtschaft
die Idee, die wir haben müssen
Menschen, die 10 Milliarden besitzen 50
Milliarden 100 Milliarden und das, wenn überhaupt
hatte nur 1 Milliarde statt
100 dann würden sie aufhören
Arbeit und er hätte mehr
wirtschaftliche Anreize
wenn du willst, fehlt es furchtbar
gesunden Menschenverstand und vor allem und vor allem nicht
berücksichtigt nicht die Lehren von
Geschichte, denn wenn wir vergleichen, wenn wir
Vergleichen Sie diese historischen Perioden
Wir sehen heute z.
Vereinigten Staaten gibt es noch viel mehr
Milliardäre in den 2000er und 2010er Jahren
als in den 70er 80er
haben wir mehr Innovation
Wachstum der Produktivität von
Löhne und Einkommen nicht die
Wachstum hat sich halbiert, so wir
Sehen Sie sich einige an, wenn Sie das Gespräch wünschen
dass dieses Anreizsystem mehr zulässt
des kollektiven Wohlstands
es ist eine Rede, die hätte sein können
wahr ja aus theoretischer sicht
das ist alles was du sagst
möglich, aber auf der Grundlage von
historische Erfahrungen, die wir haben
Es tut mir leid, aber es funktioniert nicht für mich
sehr gut diese Maya-Stadt beschneidet die
Sommer nein nein überhaupt nicht nein werde ich
geben Sie ein Beispiel dort in der
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf in den Vereinigten Staaten
der Demokratischen Partei haben Sie keinen Zweifel
folgten, dass mehrere Kandidaten in
insbesondere Elizabeth Warren Lehrerin
direkt bei harvard ist es nicht a
Guerillas, dieser Chavista ist Bernie
Sanders, das ist eher ein
Pragmatischer Sozialdemokrat im Osten
in den Zähnen die politische Waage
europäisch
beide fast zusammengebracht
die Hälfte der Stimmen in der Vorwahl
Demokrat de Juni und die überwiegende Mehrheit
Wählerstimmen unter 50
Jahre, was man nicht vergessen darf, dass das 18
29 Jahre alt, wo die 30-44-Jährigen unterstützt
Sanders und Warren viel viel mehr
dieser Biden muss in Erinnerung bleiben
in der kommenden Kampagne, wenn sie wollen
Diese beiden Sanders-Kandidaten zusammenzubringen und
Warren schlug vor, in den Vereinigten Staaten zu schaffen
eine eidgenössische Vermögenssteuer also
in den vereinigten staaten gibt es eine bundeseinkommensteuer
Einkommen
seit 1913 eine Bundessteuer auf
Güter
seit 1916 hat may nie eine steuer gehabt
Bundesregierung zum Erbe
diese beiden Kandidaten während vorgeschlagen
diese Kampagne, um eine Steuer vorzuschlagen
Bundesvermögen bis 8
% pro Jahr auf Multimilliardäre daher
das heißt, wenn du 100 hast
Milliarden zahlen Sie 8 Milliarden
in Steuern pro Jahr, also indem Sie sagen, Sie haben
80 Milliarden gezahlt
das zweite Element des Vorschlags für
Sanders und Warren ist zu sagen, ob Sie
wollen die Vereinigten Staaten mit Ihrem verlassen
Glück kannst du, aber du musst gehen
40 % Wegzugssteuer in den Vereinigten Staaten, damit Sie
sehen Sie, dass Sie tatsächlich verpflichtet sind
wenn Sie eine solche Politik machen
du musst fragen
Teil der Regeln auf kostenlos
Bewegung des Kapitals
aber diese Regeln müssen sowieso
geändert werden und neben dir
in der Schweiz erlebt hatte, weil
Erinnern Sie sich, als Obama hatte
hatte der Schweizer 2010 das Geheimnis verraten
Banking ist sehr nett, aber ich
möchte, dass die Schweiz mir die schickt
Angaben zum Steuerzahler
Amerikaner, die Konten in der Schweiz haben
zunächst hat die schweiz damals nein gesagt
dann sagte obama, wenn du nein sagst
Ich entziehe die Banklizenz von
Schweizer Banken in den USA und dann
dann hat die schweiz ja gesagt wenn du so bist
wollen diese Regeln kostenlos
Bewegung des Kapitals
sie haben nichts Natürliches sind sie nicht
in Marmor gemeißelt
Sie wurden irgendwann entworfen
und sie müssen sich weiterentwickeln, weil wir
entstanden in den 80er Jahren mit der
Abkommen über die Freizügigkeit von
Kapital ohne öffentliche Regulierung
wir haben eine Art heiliges Recht darauf geschaffen
ein Vermögen in einem Land machen mit
die öffentliche Infrastruktur des Landes
Bildungssystem
das Rechtssystem des Landes oft in
basierend auf öffentlichem Wissen
mit all dem ein Vermögen gemacht und dann
Sie können eine Taste drücken
Vermögen in ein anderes Land transferieren
und niemand weiß, wem es gehört
was wo und nach dreißig jahren wir
ist überrascht, pünktlich ah bah slim zu sagen
wir wissen nicht mehr, wem was wo gehört
wird gezwungen sein, am meisten zu verlangen
arm und bürgerlich weil
dass sie zumindest bewegungslos sind, aber
du verstehst, dass dies das macht
dass danach die Leute hassen
Globalisierung, um auf Ihre zurückzukommen
Frage, wie machen wir in einem
niederlande der vorschlag da wer war
hergestellt in den usa von warren and
Sanders war meiner Meinung nach perfekt
glaubwürdig, das heißt, es hätte sein können
gehen und ich denke, eines Tages wird es sein
gilt hoffentlich für die USA
Biden wird die Intelligenz haben, um fortzufahren
dieser Vorschlag von Warren und Sanders
weil ich es gut finde
Vorschlag für die Vereinigten Staaten
und das würde es möglich machen, zu wiederholen
wählen auch eine junge Volkswählerschaft
das erfordert mehr Umverteilung und
die die Herabsetzung verlangen
Ungleichheiten in den Vereinigten Staaten gut, wenn dies der Fall ist
wird nicht sofort angewendet
wird später angewendet, die Sie haben
Das ist sogar in Deutschland der Party aufgefallen
Deutscher Sozialdemokrat jetzt
fordert die Wiedereinführung einer Steuer auf
der Reichtum
In Deutschland war das nicht der Fall
überhaupt vor fünf oder zehn Jahren
wo die sozialdemokratische Partei Sir
so all diese Debatten über die Frage der
Vermögensteuer sind Debatten
die sich sehr schnell entwickelt
es ist ein Highlight von dem, was ich
fast genau habe ich eine ihrer Seite gelegt
ein riesiger antichristlicher Verkauf an die
jad Chorsänger der Reta diese Grunt Tea Party
Ideologie hat auch
nein dem stimme ich weitgehend zu
mit den prinzipien von john rawls at a
theoretische Ebene
das problem ist, dass john rawls ist
bleibt auf einem zu theoretischen Niveau
genau diese Länder, dass sie was ausdrücken
Prinzip, aber sie studieren nicht wirklich
was das konkret bedeutet
Stufe
von Gleichheit und Ungleichheit akzeptiert hat und
Das Ergebnis ist, dass sehr oft die
John-rawls-Prinzip wurde verwendet
Rechtswidrigkeit zu rechtfertigen
hier wird es problematisch
Also mir ist es ein Geist da
hinter den Köpfen
zumindest ist es genau so gemeint
Ich glaube, ich habe einen
mehr historischen Ansatz als John Crawls
stimmt grundsätzlich dem Grundsatz zu
ist sehr gut, aber aber Dinge
Interessant beginnt beim Hinsehen
wie konkret was ist das
impliziert als Höhe der Besteuerung
welche Ebene bedeutet es
der Ungleichheit und so ich, das ist es, das ist es
Das ist mein Ansatz, denke ich
Ich versuche, in meinem Buch zu definieren
Die richtige Gesellschaft für mich ist a
Gesellschaft, die es ermöglicht, alles zu gewähren
die größtmöglichen Rechte in
Bedingungen für den Zugang zu Grundgütern
was ist gesundheitserziehung
sondern ganz allgemein Teilnahme
zum demokratischen gesellschaftlichen Wirtschaftsleben
und so können die Ungleichheiten sein
gerechtfertigt, soweit sie
Zugriff auf Rechte erweitern
grundlegend für alle daher ist es a
Prinzip, das ziemlich nah dran ist
prinzipien von john rawls außer mir
Ich versuche, historisch zu sehen, wie weit
dies impliziert in Bezug auf das Niveau der Gleichheit
der Ungleichheiten und für einmal I
ist der Ansicht, dass wir sehr stark können
Verringerung der Ungleichheiten in Bezug auf
aktuelle Niveaus
in den Vereinigten Staaten sicher, aber auch
im Vergleich zu aktuellen Niveaus in
Europa, diese zu seinen befriedigen
Grundsätzen zu seinen Grundsätzen der Gerechtigkeit
Es wird also keine vollständige Gleichberechtigung geben
vollständige Gleichberechtigung ist nicht ist nicht
wünschenswert, weil Einzelpersonen sind
unterschiedlich
Einige Personen werden setzen wollen
alle ihre Prioritäten auf die Tatsache
besitze mehr Dinge als mehr
monetäre Einkünfte von anderen Personen
werden sich mehr Gedanken über den Umzug machen
Zeit für andere Aktivitäten ohne
Geldgeschäfte und ihre Unterschiede
zwischen Individuen sind perfekt sind
völlig legitim, aber Sie müssen nicht
Verwenden Sie dieses Prinzip dann
alles im Namen im Namen rechtfertigen
von
Erhaltung des Vorteils von
Gewinner kommen noch
das ist also nur eine illusion
das heißt, dass wir keinen Reichtum haben können
die Produktion von Reichtum und a
Reichtum im Allgemeinen ist immer sozial
und kollektiv in seinen Ursprüngen ist es
sagen, dass wir uns auf ein System verlassen
der öffentlichen Infrastruktur
Öffentliche Kenntnisse
Bill Gates hat er nicht erfunden
der Computer sammelte sich ganz allein an
Tausende von Twitter-Konten
Wissenschaftler, die geforscht haben
die ihr Scheckbuch nicht abgelegt haben
am Ende jedes ihrer Artikel
Wissenschaftler und es ist all dies
öffentliches Wissen angesammelt durch
Menschheit seit Jahrzehnten
Jahrhunderte erlauben es uns
heute und so können wir das nicht
Idee, dass wir einen Beitrag isolieren können
streng individuell ist es a
Illusion
Privateigentum ist eine Schöpfung
menschliche Gesellschaften, sich selbst zu organisieren
es ist eine gute Schöpfung, weil es so ist
nützlich, Privateigentum zu haben
von angemessener Größe für
einzelne Aktionen koordinieren
in einem dezentralen System
Wir brauchen das Privateigentum von a
angemessener Maßstab, damit jeder
kann bis zum Ende seiner Projekte für gehen
diese unterschiedliche Subjektivität
individuelle unterschiedliche Vorstellungen
Einzelne können sich ausdrücken
aber das rechtfertigt a
Privateigentum für alle Größenordnungen
vernünftig, aber Privateigentum
einer übermäßigen Konzentration kann nicht
nicht mit dieser Art gerechtfertigt werden
Erwägung
er wird bei tring defra vor Gericht gestellt
kheireddine an Mr. Green Side Who
bei frag versuchen wir es wird ein großer erfolg
dann fallen mir erstmal die ich zeige
in diesem Buch, dass die Frage nach
Ungleichheiten und die Frage nach der Herausforderung
Klima sind eng miteinander verbunden, das heißt
Sagen Sie, wenn wir nachsehen, zeige ich es herein
Das in dem Buch sind Forschungen, die
Wir haben im Labor auf die gemacht
Globale Ungleichheiten in der Schule
Wettwirtschaft
die 1% des Planeten, die die emittieren
mehr Kohlenstoff emittieren sie alle
nur mehr CO2-Emissionen als
50 % des Planeten, die am wenigsten emittieren
von Kohlenstoff also, wenn wir mit beginnen
Emissionen drastisch reduzieren
Kohlenstoff an der Spitze der Verteilung
Welt
wir werden nicht dorthin gelangen, weil es bereits ist
einen großen Teil der Gesamtemissionen
und dann können wir nicht fragen
zu den ärmsten 50 % des Planeten
vor allem in südlichen Ländern zu machen
Bemühungen, wenn wir nicht mit beginnen
mehr Aufwand verlangen
wohlhabend vor allem im Norden die
viel mehr emittieren als alle anderen
also ohne Verringerung der Ungleichheiten gibt es
kein Weg zur Nüchternheit
Energie
Zweitens müssen wir uns ändern
im Grunde die Indikatoren von
wirtschaftlicher Fortschritt so zum Beispiel die
Bruttoinlandsprodukt
es ist kein guter Indikator für den Fortschritt
wirtschaftlich und ich schlage immer vor
in meiner Forschung zu verwenden
Präferenz
insbesondere andere Indikatoren
der Volkseinkommensindikator, der
besteht darin, das innere Produkt zu entfernen
roh
nicht nur Kapitalerträge
ins Ausland gehen sondern auch das ganze
Kapitalverzehr u
insbesondere des Naturkapitals, so I
Nimm ein Beispiel, wenn du aus dem Boden kommst
100 Milliarden Euro Kohlenwasserstoffe
und das und du legst sie auf den Boden
Sie werden 100 Milliarden Euro haben
Rohr des Bruttoinlandsprodukts oder wenn
Sie nehmen 100 Milliarden Euro ab
Fisch im Ozean, wo gehandelt wird
in den Boden, um sie zu fressen, das sind 100
Milliarden Euro Inlandsprodukt
roh
sondern vom Standpunkt des Volkseinkommens
es ist null euro, weil du hast
einfach den vorhandenen Vorrat aufgebraucht
bereits Kapital und wenn zusätzlich bei Ihnen
diese Kohlenwasserstoffe verbrennen
Sie erhöhen die Temperatur auf der Erde
und dass es verhindert, richtig zu leben
auf der Erde
Also, wenn Sie einen Preis auf seinen setzen
Kohlenstoffemissionen
in der Tat werden Sie ein Einkommen haben
nationales Negativ daher für dasselbe
wirtschaftlicher Betrieb
Entweder man hat ein Bruttoinlandsprodukt
positives oder negatives Nationaleinkommen
so sehen wir, dass sich die Indikatoren ändern
wirtschaftlichen Fortschritt zu messen
kann die Vision komplett verändern
dass wir was zu tun haben, wir gehen
Zweitens müssen Sie sich darauf einlassen
Berücksichtigung der nationalen Einkommensungleichheit
und nicht nur das Aggregat
Makroökonomie des Inlandsprodukts
roh oder national und drittens es
muss man auch berücksichtigen
ausschließlich Umweltindikatoren
wie CO2-Emissionen, sondern auch
auf Biodiversität
Also, wenn wir, wenn wir uns nicht ändern
radikal die Art und Weise, wie wir die messen
sehr Begriff des wirtschaftlichen Fortschritts und
Sozial
Wir werden die Stadt nicht erreichen
[Musik]
Eskalation der Krise in Sharm el Sheikh
Ägypten-Spiel, das man zumindest lernen kann
dieser Krise dieser Gesundheitskrise
ist das gemeinsam können wir
bei Bedarf ändern
Spielregeln der Wirtschaft
und dort in diesem Fall mit dieser Krise
sanitär
Wir beschließen, dass wir einen großen stoppen müssen
ein Teil der wirtschaftlichen Aktivitäten stoppen
den größten Teil des Luftverkehrs
und es ist immer noch interessant, weil
das vor ein paar wochen
ein paar Monate, als wir das gesagt haben
die Vereinbarungen von Paris einhalten
musste den Flugverkehr reduzieren
CO2-Emissionen sollen reduziert werden
da sagten alle ganz unmöglich
für die Wirtschaft
es wird auch einen wirtschaftlichen Preis haben
wichtig und plötzlich da für a
Epidemie, die im Moment immerhin gleich ist
verursacht weit weniger Todesfälle als die
Grippe oder das oder das viele andere
Umweltschäden im Zusammenhang mit der
schlechte Luftqualität zum Beispiel
das macht Zehntausende
tot jedes jahr dort haben wir uns nie verändert
nichts über Wirtschaftsregulierung
Was es also zeigt, ist das auf der
Fragen der Gesundheitsüberwachung
Wir haben Warnmechanismen entwickelt
und Eingriffe in das Wirtschaftsleben
teilweise sehr anspruchsvoll
vielleicht zu raffiniert schließlich ich
denke, dass es insgesamt diese sind
Mechanismen, die aber gerechtfertigt sind
muss sich jetzt entwickeln
Risikomechanismen
Umwelt versus Risiko
soziale auf die Ungleichheiten, die sind
längerfristige Risiken, die geringer sind
plötzliche Gewaltrisiken wie a
Epidemie, die aber letztendlich lange dauert
Begriff sind daher mindestens genauso wichtig
Ich hoffe, dass wir uns wenigstens daran erinnern werden
diese Krise
dass wir hier können und müssen
regulieren gemeinsam die Kräfte
wirtschaftlich zu garantieren a
sozialer Ausgleich für die für die
äußerst zerbrechliche menschliche Gesellschaften
in denen in denen wir
lebe die Krise
dank der Kapitalideologie und dem Blitz, der
war ihr mann andré in grüner form
royalistische Familienaromen über Janish
Schuljahr grüne Musikfreunde gegründet
von Experten dieses Gas
libé de slade petra
[Musik]